ezra miller got arrested again this time
apparently they threw a chair and it hit
somebody in the head
so the fact that they have now been
arrested again before even the last
batch of trouble from when they were
arrested just a week or so ago has been
sorted out
yeah that's uh that's not good people
have been asking me does this change my
opinion of
of what i think will happen or won't
happen with the flash not
really i will still be shocked
if they attempt to reshoot the entire
movie if things continue to spiral they
might push it back again
um i do think it increases the
likelihood or at least the possibility
of so one of the things that is rumored
to be in this is that there are multiple
barry allens but they're all played by
israel miller i wouldn't be shocked if
they did reshoots to put a new actor as
one of the alternate barry allens who
can then take over the franchise going
forward
that i could see happening
i still expect the movie to come out
though they spend too much money